making a decision out of fears never the
right decision right right right so like
you're thinking about doing this but my
fear is if that's the reason why you're
not saying yes and that's you don't want
to live your life based off of all your
fears of what might happen you need to
watch what you self worth to tie your
self-worth to the effort not the results
because if you're saying oh I got
results I'm getting good at this
and now I'm starting to like it more
like the reason for you liking it more
shouldn't be because you're getting the
victories on it because that's a trap
where a lot of people in they're
becoming great accountants because
they're good at it but they actually
don't they just acquired the skill at it
and somebody told them they were good at
it but they actually want to be a singer
like how can we like focus on quality
relationships in life okay because I
really feel like having good
relationships and being able to connect
with people who are on a higher level
will help you get that much faster to
where you want to be in life yeah and to
just management of like life and
relationships in general
okay people who are like okay you know
influential so you got it so it's a
first off for the relationships
absolutely if you can be around people
who are pushing you forward who you can
learn from I think I would group it into
two categories one of aggressive peers
who are off doing stuff so it was one of
the challenges I had at university
nobody was at that time how old am I am
38 okay
entrepreneurship wasn't as popular and
none of my friends wanted to be
entrepreneurs I said I was kind of like
the only one doing my thing but if you
are around other people at your school
who are also like aggressively pushed
yeah right and like seek those people
out as opposed to just being solo it can
give you extra ammunition extra
motivation in terms of reaching out to
other people who could be your mentors
for different things
the best thing to do I think I think he
played it right with sage like there was
an event you wanted to meet me I was
speaking about I said I was gonna be
there it's like that my goal I want to
meet Evan and as
question yeah and that's the best thing
you do is is get on like go find
somebody meet them and ask one question
yeah ask one question and then whatever
the most important question is for you
and then go do something about it yeah
because this is a challenging thing
about mentorship mentors love giving
back fencers love giving back it's it's
one of the greatest things of all time
because people are built to serve and so
if if they see in you like a younger
version of themselves and you see I want
to help this guy right then then they
love doing it yeah the problem is most
mentees suck and never do the work right
so because it's giant waste of time
right right and so the thing that they
they love the most which is giving back
and helping and feeling in a service is
now matched with the thing they hate the
most which is wasting time okay so the
challenge becomes how do you separate
yourself from all the other people who
are pinging them trying to meet them
trying to get on their radar right
there's a really good point you get
lumped in with everybody else who's
saying the same thing right sadly so
that's why you don't want to go to
somebody say hey we'd be my mentor yeah
because that's that's like a
relationship that's going up with
somebody on the street say hey will you
marry me oh yeah it shows a disrespect
for them because they understand what
mentorship is and it shows your
ignorance around the topic it's also
just like just being rushed in general
you know relationships take time and a
lot of nurturing it's kind of like a
fire you know you just started small
you've got a lot of hunger a lot of
ambition
definitely definitely easy to get along
with when when somebody's meeting you
they'll see like okay this guy has some
potential to do stuff yeah which is
great it puts you ahead of a lot of
people but there's still a lot of people
who have all that same exact talk a big
game but then don't do anything exactly
so that so then it's the action it's the
doing what K what are you gonna do like
come with one question and then go home
and work on that answer they gave you so
if you ask somebody if you ask me a
question and I give you an answer go
home and try it what most people do is
they'll ask the question they may try it
they'll think about it and then they'll
come back and ask another question and
then the last another question like did
you do with the work on the first
question that we talking about you have
to go off and do the work
and either you do the work and it worked
then you come back and ask the second
question say hey you gave me that advice
at work awesome now I'm here now I'm
struggling to get to the next spot or
you do the work and you try it a hundred
times and it doesn't work and you go
back and say like I took your advice I
tried it a hundred times it didn't work
yeah what's more important than the the
result is the effort yeah so you took
the advice and you try to do something
you put in the effort where most mentees
will never put in the effort yeah we'll
just think their way out of it yeah and
so that's one of the most frustrating
things of all time
even people who message me on DMS and
you know I make a video response and say
here's gonna go do this and it's a hell
but how about like another question go
do the first one Yeah right and so even
though your long-term goal may be
mentorship they not thinking that from
the first time they're meeting you yeah
so you're going with one question do the
work on it then come back for a second
way right and if you've done the work
either you've got the results or not
they'll want to talk to you again
because you did the work you put in the
effort mm-hmm right and so that's if you
have a list of targeted people that like
I would love to me this person this
person this person this person I I met
someone in Reno Nevada I was there for
ecommerce yeah I'm conference and men by
the name of David he's got unreal guy
and he's been my mentor for about three
months now okay um
it started off really really slow yeah
just like ask him questions to remiel
and whatnot and now I'm working for him
and I asked him I was like can I work
for you yeah as an intern and so he got
me a job as an intern yeah and he runs
his own e-commerce firm okay and I just
do a bunch of product listings for him
okay and my goal with it was to be able
to just learn how he has his entire
organization set up how he runs his
entire management how he has you know
all the information flows through the
company yeah how he sets up all the
supply chain and whatnot I wanted to
learn all that I'm not really learning
that yeah because I'm still based in
Toronto and he's in Montreal okay so at
one point I wanted to make the switch
but I have a decision to make switch
what to go to Montreal yeah and and and
work at the office with him because I
think that the environment is the most
important thing okay in general and I
wasn't able to make the switch because
you got school I got school to finish
yeah and it picks up in January again
right so I'm kind of faced with a
decision you know he offered me a
full-time job yeah which is awesome for
a year yeah but I don't know whether or
not to take it or not
yeah it's a tough call it is it's a big
it's a really long term you know thing
that I'm taking up taking on if I'm
going into e-commerce it's like I'm
gonna do this yeah and this is the
industry I'm diving in and from there
I'll be able to diverge but whether
whether you whether you end up sticking
in e-commerce or not isn't as important
yeah it's it's how much you're gonna
learn and grow in that year are you
gonna get the are you gonna get the
opportunity that you really want being
there with him okay so back it up do you
I think education is a great back-up
plan
yep I think if you if you absolutely
know that you want to be an entrepreneur
and there's no other option then school
is not gonna mean much to you
right if you don't know if you want to
be an entrepreneur it's something you're
thinking about in trying but like you're
not a hundred percent it's good to have
school as a back-up plan
yeah because if you just have a high
school degree it's a lot harder to get
yeah some kind of job afterwards yeah
all the entrepreneurs probably know that
are watching right now the second you
say you know is entrepreneurship for you
it's like a 150 million percent in my
brain yeah it's like the road I'm gonna
go down there's no question about it
that I'm not gonna be an entrepreneur I
think that you know most people who want
to be entrepreneurs it stems from just
being very creative in general people
who like to be creative I find they want
to be entrepreneurs because at a
corporate job you don't really have much
say on you know where the company's
direction is gonna go how you're gonna
you know what you're gonna do in the
future what new innovation are you gonna
work on that's an entrepreneur okay but
if you're 150 percent in then then just
take a year off and go work for him
the issue with that the issue with that
is uh is uh it's kind of like the fear
that I have inside I've talked with my
Dean and she said if you take a year off
yeah you will have to you know go
through the entire application process
again to get back into your program and
right now I only have like a seventy
three overall the arch isn't really
strong yeah I came into the school like
an 82 yeah with a scholarship which is
awesome yeah but it's it might it might
backfire I don't know how it's gonna go
it's just a bigger risk in general but I
guess that's what I'm Traverse alright
well making a decision out of fears
never the right decision right right
right so like you're thinking about
doing this but my fear is if that's the
reason why you're not saying yes and
that's you don't want to live your life
based off of all your fears of what
might happen yeah right so the worst
case is you go and you work for him and
you know you hate it in like two weeks
in you're like oh my gosh this is like
the worst thing of all time whether
that's before this sucks right so then
so then okay if this is gonna be your
year of entrepreneurship then then if
that guy sucks and and you don't want to
work there anymore then spend the next
year focused on your business like we'll
find another mentor like make it yeah
this is your shot go off and do it yeah
but if your hundred fifty percent in
like you're you're what are you going to
accounting finance and economics is what
I had yeah oh you U of T where are you
I'm at bishops in Quebec Quebec okay so
I so I went to U of T Rob yeah under
finance and economics like it served me
zero for what I do nobody asked me what
school anomalies though in general is a
very very good base for just
understanding society it's okay but it's
too macro like I love Mac I thought
economics was the answer to everything
economics was like I loved it like it
all makes it you just put on these
graphs and if this goes up and it's good
then it's just too macro yeah in in as
an entrepreneur it's it's almost zero
the relevancy if you want to go and
being an economist I work at a giant
company great but as an entrepreneur
like it's just it's too I was I was the
economics guy
but it's like almost zero value compared
to what you could be doing like if you
go out went off and had the year
experience learning you'll you'll learn
way more but how to actually yeah be an
entrepreneur then you will from an
economics textbook okay so make that
your year and if it's a little tougher
when you come back like if it doesn't
work and you say you know what I want to
I want to work at a company I want to
get my finish my you know economics
degree and go get a job then you it'll
be tougher but what's the alternative
you spend two years and missed this
opportunity
exactly exactly yeah what did you do was
there like specific like planning things
that you did to like just move forward
or is just like just a brute force
action to just the I love planning I
love strategy I love thinking I love
research child modelling success you
know and this this is just planning yeah
I love I love that what's planning for
you it's content right this is my 95 but
but for you it's a 5 right like people
who show up to seminars and advance it
up it's great but it's just the learning
is awesome but some of the smartest
people with the most learning end up
never being successful entrepreneurs
because you're not doing enough cuz
they're just thinking like a lot of
academics that they try to launch a
business and they never take off they
have all the knowledge they have all the
smarts they know they're in the street
but they never have entrepreneurial
success
there's geniuses who just never make it
as an entrepreneur because they're stuck
in their own head they're not doing like
somebody who's super than you will win
because I just did it yeah even the
thinking around the whole like should I
leave and go do that job or it's just
too much thinking yeah
get out of your head like go and do it
it feels right go do it yeah for smart
people you have to learn to listen to
your heart more and just take action
yeah because it's the fear that then
prevents you from going off and yeah
building something amazing yeah and so
the more you can quash that fear and
just do so when people say well that
that guy made money off of my idea that
was my idea and he when he made millions
all right so no like you just sat on it
well he went off and did something about
it exactly right he's
there's too wet and you deserve to lose
not to sit here and complain you deserve
to lose you didn't take the action on it
so it's action when you first started
yeah and you because momentum I know
that life has a lot of momentum waves
and you have to learn how to ride them
and you will fall certain times and
that's what people call like you know
failure I guess you could say when you
fall you break those momentum waves I'm
how do you get out of breaking momentum
waves and like get back right back in as
soon as I feel something is off then I
have to make a change and it's usually
in my schedule usually my habits because
you are what you consistently do right
and so I'll look at if I'm feeling I'm
missing something
I'm feeling this doesn't drive me
anymore I feel like if this if this was
ah I gotta come at me Sebastian like the
morning show this sucks I'm done here it
close it right I'll walk away from it at
some point that YouTube channel I'm
gonna just walk away from because I'm
not gonna feel it anymore it's gonna be
something else for me to do and right
and then thank you guys for the love I'm
yeah right yeah that's that's how I
operate like if my heart side into
anymore I'm not feeling it then I look
at I look ideally you look for ways to
tweak it while you still have one foot
in the pool yeah you're feeling little
like you're feeling yourself distancing
from it and you catching the calm not as
interested in this as I used to be can I
tweak it to make it fit what I want to
do or not and then move on to the next
thing I find that also you kind of lose
interest but you you gain interest in
stuff that you're good at you lose
interest in stuff that you suck at you
need to watch what you sell forth to tie
yourself worth to the effort not the
results okay because if you're saying oh
I got results I'm getting good at this
and now I'm starting to like it more
like the reason for you liking it more
shouldn't be because you're getting the
victories on it because that's a trap
we're a lot of people in that becoming
great accountants because they're good
at it but they actually don't they just
acquired the skill at it and somebody
told them they were good at it
but they actually want to be a saying
right where you should tie your tie
yourself worth to the the effort of it
like am I am I am I love in the process
of doing this not am I getting the
results because I mean if you if you
work harder than anything you'll get
good at it
yeah even videos I'm think I'm a slow
learner on the video side I've got 6,000
videos on my channel and the first 350 I
was embarrassed by embarrassed like I
couldn't watch it I could play it 350
videos most people quit way before that
yeah
and 700 something before I inspired
myself or I look at the video like man
that's like good so I feel like I am a
super slow I wasn't getting the results
I wasn't getting views and comments I
wasn't but I'd like the the process of
it yeah and so you can get good at
almost anything if you talk about
entrepreneurship you can get good at
almost anything and turn that into a
successful business right but if you're
only watching what comes there's nothing
wrong with with what you're getting
faster results at yeah but just don't
make that the only breaking point the
only decision point okay because like
anything economics you not you're just
gonna you'll pick up faster then then
something else and piano or soccer or
speaking or something else is because
you've gone to school and you've learned
it but doesn't mean that's the thing
that you should be doing for the rest of
your life mmm-hmm definitely I think
that right now for my standpoint what
what what I'm lacking is not the work
ethic the work ethic has been there
since 98 yeah what I'm lacking is the
right steps and I think that's what most
people yeah but here's the thing there's
no perfect right step but there are
critical steps for whatever venture your
project you're working on to get the
intended result for someone like you
it's just going out and taking more new
steps right because it's overthinking
things can you model success yes it's
the name of my channel is modeling the
Masters I love it
right but I thought I was believed no
more my channel
as modeling the Masters like ever
youtube.com slash China or whatever okay
you believe is my is my one word and you
know the missions focus nice so so the
problem is if you're if you're super
well you know focus sound like I need to
find the next to step you won't you
won't think your way through it like you
you're not gonna figure it out sitting
on the couch like I can't tell you if
this guy is gonna work out in Montreal
right you'll never figure it out yeah no
matter how smart you are and how many
options and like who else did whatever
you won't know until you go off and do
it yeah so you have to go off and do it
yeah and and then just be willing to
bail on something if it's not working
right like if school is not working
you're gonna bail on and go do something
else
yeah and then find that next thing and
then bail on that if it's not working
out like don't spend a year with this
guy three months in you realize this
sucks
yeah but I can't get back to my school I
got no other plan so I'm just gonna stay
here no like next yeah bail on daddy
what's the maximum enter right and then
you won't know until you go off and try
that next thing so you know I you just
probably seen those those diagrams were
like success is not this straight line
this is massively squiggly crazy thing
as long as you're making progress you're
moving every day but thinking does not
count as moving moving counts as moving
you can't think about moving you have to
move okay right and here's the thing
you're you're so naturally just you'll
you'll never abandon the planning side
me yeah myself yeah I think that that's
more so because I I think they that's
not just myself I think that that's
generations in general that's how it's a
personality thing that's not generations
yeah like some people some people are
artists some people they're people who
plan too much and people who do too much
you can do too much you could just be
yeah whatever I have no plan yeah just
be opt-in and a bunch of stuff and you
just not running in circles with you
don't know what forward looks like
because you're not thinking enough yeah
but that's not you
yeah you think too much and plain too
much and so you'll never go all the way
to the other side the fear is I won't
know what I'm doing and I'm gonna lose
direction and I'm just gonna go in
circles and spin my wheels and just be
the guy who does but never has
nice trap you'll never be that guy right
because you default into that mode
default into that mode defaulted into
overthinking things
yeah so you have to go off and start
doing more how do you know what mode you
defaulted in general sort of like
specific things that like well just just
here just in Utah yeah so how could you
figure out what mode you defaulted it I
lost a forty million dollar deal really
yeah
so what mode is your default I'm the
same thing over thank you yeah I lost a
forty million dollar deal when I was 22
because I was overthinking Oh got to be
the perfect thing and I had the sad
entire summer doing a business plan and
figuring out all the exact steps and and
I lost a forty million dollar deal like
main that sucks right and I don't want
you to have to lose a similar equivalent
yeah you know like lose an opportunity
this guy and then that's the thing that
now you realize crap I overthought it
and I didn't take action right right so
so now it's it's focused on momentum
it's as soon as you get an idea I have
to try it right now if we want to get
real personal it's more so like just
being able to manage my relationship
with mom dad and not really my little
brother but like my parents it's I've
kind of been so used to living at
university yeah that now that I'm at
home in Toronto yeah it's it's a lot
harder to just be able to have my own
independence and being able to just I
guess you could say focus on myself okay
because there's just so many tasks and
things that my parents they still treat
me like a little kid okay and it's you
know not that I don't think that yeah
they're bad people with they just still
have that mindset of I'm a little boy
yeah and I don't think anymore yeah so
it's it's a little bit more difficult to
be able to manage that relationship
which is why I want to ask you how do
you like manage relationships and how do
you like you know even if you're really
upset how do you just snap out of that
mood and you just like alright let's sit
down at dinner and let's have a good
conversation with our parents because
often times it's it's not like that I
think I come
like I didn't do anything today I'm just
like so beat up and I didn't get any
progress done and my mom just gets angry
at me my dad gave me think of a movie
for what just cuz there cuz I'm not
seeing any results oh and your business
yeah alright but your school still now
no I'm right now I'm not at school okay
I'm taking you semester all school oh
you took a semester off already
yeah focus on your business and already
telling them that I'm taking a semester
off
yeah was like you know going back into
late yeah what's that yeah you know I
told them I'm not going back and so
they're really just kind of upset yeah
because they think that if I don't go
back obviously be success yeah yeah well
it's okay first officer it's
understanding that's all that I love
right like they love you they just see
success is a different path than what
you see it and honestly like you know
your parents are pilgrims like the idea
that you can make money from a cell
phone yeah right is ridiculous they're
just they just don't see the world they
grew up with but they were your age is
insanely different than even from them
to their parents Yeah right
and so they love you they want you to be
successful they don't understand the
world that currently exist now like
somebody who are you 22
I just turned 20 20 like when they were
20 they got zero respect they were 20
it's like go work at a company get
coffee like entry-level really boring
stuff and so you work your way up to
then you know you're 30 40 50 you know
what you're doing you get some more
respect you say like people now respect
20 year-olds way more than ever before
yeah right like you got you got 60 year
old executives trying to figure out
Instagram right they're coming to 20
year olds right say how do we do this
right and there's never been more
successful teenage and early 20th
entrepreneurs in history right like by
next year you could be making more than
your parents mm-hmm so so that's that
level of empathy and understanding
already for you just to like try to
process it that this is still all out of
love they just don't understand success
the same way
the conversation I would have would be
saying that this is this is a moment in
time for you this is your dream that you
need to chase and and you have to you
feel like if you don't figure it out
you're gonna regret it for the rest of
your life right I need to do this for me
it may not work like if you go in the
challenge in these discussions often is
you go in thinking of course it's gonna
work you always be always presenting
such a front to the parents it's like
this is gonna work out it's amazing and
they're all thinking holy cow he's so
blind about he has no idea what he's
talking about he's gonna fail and most
entrepreneurs do fail right now you've
already failed a couple times awesome
like that's part of the part of the
journey right but if you go in and say
this may not work you know like this
business version right now probably
won't work if you just look at the
numbers but I still need to do it I need
to try it because otherwise I'm gonna
regret it I know I'm gonna regret it for
the rest of my life mm-hmm and you know
I may end up with no money and having to
stay home or sleep on somebody's couch
yeah for the next four years as I figure
this out and I hope that it's your couch
yeah so coming from a place for like
you're you're you're scared you don't
know how I'm not scared I just it's
obviously like no but but still I feel
like fear before you make a decision but
even that like be scared like they don't
see that side they're only seeing the
side of you saying of course it's gonna
work out and then they see you not
getting results and they think you're
delusional
and so they press harder on ya and that
just beats which makes it worse yeah so
but but then share the insecurities tell
them I don't know if I don't know how
it's gonna work out I'm worried that
it's not gonna work out I'm trying to
figure out a path because because I feel
like I have potential in this but I
don't know all the steps but I know that
if I don't do this I'm gonna regret it
the rest of my life
okay so then they see then hopefully
it's a more understanding conversation
it doesn't mean they're gonna say yeah I
quit school and but it eases attention
because if you only come off as being
confident
and thinking that it's always gonna work
out which is definitely a part you have
to have a piece of that's not like walk
around every day I suck is never gonna
work
like it's definitely a piece of it but
when when your parents see that and not
just yours in general anybody who loves
you when they see that and they're in
the back of their head thinking this
guy's crazy he doesn't think the success
rate of entrepreneurship is terrible
yeah and especially when they're coming
from a different generation then they're
gonna do their best to beat it into you
that you didn't know what you're talking
about right so if you understand them
let's say I get it like this is a risk
this may not work I'm I don't know how
it's gonna work you know I I'm
frustrated and I'm scared but I need to
do it because I'm gonna regret it
and this is this is my chance now when
I'm 20 to do it cuz when I'm 40 and have
kids and it's gonna be a lot harder for
me to take that take that really
definitely that's an easier message for
them to understand it doesn't mean
they're gonna be fully on board and say
oh everything's great go but it's an
easier conversation and it uses a
relationship compared to only coming off
saying like why don't you support me I'm
trying to build my business you know
right when you're attacking like that or
just only front in the confidence it
you're inviting combat that into your
life where you're trying to ease it yeah
yeah thank you so much for having me on
the show Evan I really appreciate it I
would do action taker right here yeah
the action believe guys if you want to
get coached by me one-on-one to help you
build your brain and make money as a
thought leader check out my next
workshop in Toronto the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there